Not all passports are created equal,...
...and those that provide the greatest freedom of movement throughout the world...
...are deemed as being the most powerful.
Arton Capital, a financial advisory firm,...
...has determined which nation's documents afford their citizens...
...the easiest way to visit another country.
Their rankings are based on the number of places a person can go...
...without being required to obtain visas or special permissions.
Passports issued by the governments...
...of both the United States and the United Kingdom...
...were declared the most powerful in the world.
The nations' travel documents tied for first place,...
...each of them granting their carriers unfettered entry to 147 countries.
Overall, places with a lot of allies fare best,...
...while those that are often in states of unrest don't come out as well.